pushed aside by the economic crisis and
the more recent refugees crisis climate
change has been overshadowed by the
European political agenda but debate on
global warming is once more put to the
fore ahead of a crucial UN climate
conference to be held in paris in
december in a report adopted by a large
majority the european parliament is
pressing for ambitious and binding
targets to be rich by 2030 yellow joseon
copa de siècle new devo fare on so to go
parte de su apartamento rational pour
sae me ansu met irrational pour des
idees impolitic applicable the failures
of the 2009 negotiations in copenhagen
are still a lively wound in the european
memory but there have been significant
scientific and political advances since
giving rise for optimism for Paris we've
got to get these targets right clearly
endorsed by all who must meet them and
we've got to make sure they were able to
audit them and deliver against them
otherwise we are not a strong player at
Paris just as we were not a particularly
strong player at Lima ask Parliament
need to ratify an agreement reached in
Paris a delegation of 15m eps we also be
there sitting at the negotiating table